vamos a resolver el siguiente problema
dice el número de valores de teta en el
intervalo menos pi medios y medios o que
este es un intervalo abierto es decir no
estamos incluyendo los extremos que son
justamente menos pi medios y medios dice
entonces el número de valores de teta en
este intervalo tales que teta no es un
múltiplo entero de pi entre 5 es decir
no es n entre 5 pero nos dicen para está
sen es 0 más o menos uno más o menos 2 y
además debe cumplir que la tangente de
teta es el laco tangente de 5 teta así
como también seno de 2 teta igual a
coseno de 4 teta aunque entonces nos
piden el número de valores de teta esas
cuál es el número de valores de eta que
cumplen todo eso y para las personas que
me conocen saben que me gusta recrear
los aspectos necesarios para resolver el
problema y recrear los aspectos teóricos
los aspectos geométricos pero si estás
la supresión de un examen no te lo
recomiendo verdad no tiene sentido que
deduzca
nuevamente las identidades
trigonométricas esto solo es para fines
educativos pero si estás presentando el
kit pues definitivamente deberías tener
ya muy bien manejado si bien memorizadas
las identidades trigonométricas pero
bueno como ahorita estamos en un vídeo
educativo vamos vamos a hacerlo
digamos tenemos aquí webs tenemos aquí
nuestro triángulo rectángulo
más o menos derechito está
muy bien tenemos un triángulo rectángulo
y digamos que este ángulo éste está muy
bien este por ser un triángulo
rectángulo es un ángulo de pi medios o
de 90 grados entonces este de aquí
necesariamente tiene que medir pi medios
menos teta verdad de tal suerte que a la
hora de sumar todos nos dé 180 grados
que es lo mismo que piden radiales muy
bien entonces ya que tenemos esto nos
preguntamos por ejemplo por el coseno el
co seno de nuestro ángulo teta el co
seno de nuestro ángulo teta y para eso
hay que hay que utilizar por ejemplo
estas estas cosas mnemotécnicas que
tenemos para recordar verdad tenemos el
sol
acá
toda la verdad esto es seno coseno y
tangente oeste opuesto adyacente hd
hipotenusa entonces el coseno que es el
de aquí es adyacente entre hipotenusa si
por ejemplo a éste le llamamos a b ya
este ese entonces para este ángulo quien
sería el el cateto adyacente pues sería
este de aquí verdad el b y la hipotenusa
sería c entonces tenemos b / c
pero fíjense muy bien fíjense muy bien
que ven 13 si ahora nos fijamos en este
ángulo es el opuesto entre hipotenusa y
eso el opuesto entre hipotenusa es el
seno entonces tenemos seno de este
ángulo de aquí que es y medios menos t
está muy bien entonces de entrada
tenemos esta igualdad esta igualdad se
da simplemente de ver cómo están
definidas las funciones trigonométricas
en este triángulo rectángulo muy bien lo
mismo podríamos pensar por ejemplo para
él
de este ángulo el seno de este ángulo es
el opuesto entre hipotenusa entonces
sería a entre la hipotenusa que es ce
que también es lo mismo que el coseno de
medios menos teta verdad nos fijamos en
este y queremos ver cómo es en 13 pues a
es el adyacente respecto a este ángulo a
este ángulo de aquí entonces sería el
coseno muy bien perfecto entonces
también podríamos hacer el análisis de
la otan gente y realmente porque
queremos pues porque aquí nos están
relacionando la tangente con la co
tangente muy bien entonces por ejemplo
ya aterrizando lo en este tipo de
cuentas por ejemplo tenemos con tangente
de 5 teta pues esto por definición es
uno entre la tangente la tangente es
seno entre coseno y como es el recíproco
entonces va a ser coseno de 5 teta entre
de 5 t está muy bien entonces no tenemos
que lo mismo da por ejemplo cómo tenemos
que el coche no de cualquier ángulo es
el seno de pi medios menos ese ángulo
aquí podemos poner seno de medios menos
5 teta entre y aquí el pse no lo podemos
expresar como un coche en la verdad
coseno de pi medios menos
5 te está muy bien pero ahora fijémonos
muy bien en esta fórmula es seno de un
ángulo entre coseno de ese ángulo esto
simplemente es la tangente de pi medios
menos 5 teta y tú dirás bueno y para qué
estás haciendo todo esto y realmente lo
estoy haciendo porque la otan gente la
queremos relacionar con la tangente muy
bien al menos de esta forma sin embargo
hay que notar lo siguiente déjenme hacer
un dibujo para recordar qué es lo que
nos está diciendo la tangente ok éste
fue un círculo muy feo
mucho mejor
pongamos nuestros ejes
ahí están más o menos no importa que
esté hecho eco nos fijamos en un ángulo
theta y nos fijamos en la línea que se
genera a partir de ese ángulo theta la
tangente la tangente si recordamos es
que no entre coseno que esencialmente es
la pendiente de esta recta entonces
fíjate muy bien tienes este theta y si
nosotros le sumamos y es decir ahora nos
consideramos este ángulo entonces
tenemos que está más pi que está más pi
de está más y representa la misma recta
verdad cuando cuando generamos la línea
representa la misma recta y por lo tanto
tiene la misma la misma pendiente
entonces realmente si nosotros le
sumamos múltiplos de pi a esto no cambia
verdad entonces esto nos va a servir
para encontrar todos los valores
posibles como pues porque además le
podemos ir sumando pi
le podemos volver a sumar pinos da ya
esto otra pi y así sucesivamente y
representa esencialmente la misma línea
muy bien entonces ahora sí vamos a ir
aterrizando todo esto en nuestro
problema porque esencialmente tenemos
tangente resolver esto tangente de teta
es igual a la otan gente de cinco teta
pero realmente no quiero ponerla con
tangente de cinco teta yo ya sé que la
cota agente de 53 está tangente entonces
voy a quitarlo y voy a poner tangente de
pi medios menos 5 teta más múltiplos de
pi np n por supuesto es un número entero
muy bien entonces fíjate muy bien
tenemos tangente de algo igual a la
tangente de otra cosa pues simplemente
esas cosas tienen que ser iguales así
que tomamos teta iguala y medios menos 5
teta más
np muy bien y entonces ya nuestro
problema es de encontrar para cuáles
tetas esto se vale sumamos 5 teta de
ambos lados y nos quedan acá una y 5 son
6 teta
igual a pi medios como sumamos 5 t3 eso
se cancela y nos queda sumar n p muy
bien y ahora para despejar teta
dividimos todo en 36 de ambos lados y
nos queda teta igual a pi medios entre 6
son de entre 12
+ n sobre 6 y ya para para poder
expresar esto de forma más agradable
sacamos un denominador común que es 12
entonces tenemos pi sobre 12 más
aquí sería 2 n p / 12 verdad simplemente
dividimos arriba y abajo entre 2 y nos
queda en ep / 6 que es esto
entonces ya tenemos pido sea pido seamos
más 2n pi doceavos aquí podremos tener
una p más 12 n p es 2 n 1 que multiplica
api sobre 12 muy bien y entonces theta
tiene esta forma donde la n puede variar
en los enteros muy bien tenemos otra
ecuación tenemos por acá otra ecuación y
tenemos seno de 2 te da igual a coseno
de 4 teta vamos a escribirlo seno
seno de 230 es igual a coseno de 4 teta
pero ahora voy a utilizar esta fórmula
porque el coste no de un ángulo es
senodep y medios menos ese ángulo
entonces coseno de 4 t está será seno de
pi medios menos 4 teta y además como las
funciones en icod seno son periódicas y
de periodos dos pi le puedo sumar
múltiplos de dos pi para que esto siga
siendo igual déjenme ponerlo así para
que sea más claro son dos pi y múltiplos
es multiplicarlo por un n donde n s
entero muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos
tenemos el seno de dos teta es este seno
y por lo tanto podemos decir que este
ángulo de aquí y este de acá son el son
el mismo entonces dos teta es igual a
medios menos cuatro teta
+ 2 p m muy bien entonces si sumamos
ahora 4 teta de ambos lados vamos a
sumar teta de ambos lados 4 teta perdón
entonces dos tetas más cuatro tetas son
seis teta igual a pi medios más 2n muy
bien si porque sumamos cuatro teta y
esto se cancela
ahora bien dividimos todo en 36
dividimos de ambos lados en 36 y nos
queda t t igual a pie entre 12 más 2
viene pero pm2 viene entre 6 es lo mismo
que tiene entre 3 y ahora sacamos un
denominador común que en este caso puede
ser 12 12 entre 2 es una por espn + 12
entre 34 x tiene son cuatro pi
ok y si factor izamos lápiz tenemos 4 n
1 por pi
sobre 12 sobre 12 muy bien entonces ya
tenemos otra relación tenemos esta
primera docena más un pie entre 12 y
tenemos esta 4 n
entre 12 estos dos tetas entonces vamos
a fijarnos porque además no podemos
elegir cualquiera recordemos que no nos
podemos salir del intervalo menos y
medios y medios así que vamos a ver qué
pasa por ejemplo qué pasa tienes cero
tiene cero nos queda uno por pi entre 12
que son y entre 12 tiene es uno tenemos
dos por uno son dos más uno son 33 pi
entre 12 tenemos 3 pi entre 12 si tenés
dos tendremos dos por 24 15 tenemos 5 pi
entre 12 ahora fíjate muy bien que si
tomamos en e igual a 3 nos queda dos por
tres son seis más unas 77 pi doceavos
que eso pasa a 6 pide osea bosques y
medios
y no no debíamos de pasarnos de ahí
entonces para n igual a 3 ya no aplica
para n igual a 3 serían 7 p 12 a vos
pero esto esto de aquí es más grande que
un medio entonces eso ya no nos conviene
tomarlo ya no nos conviene tomarlo pero
podemos tomarnos en es negativa
recordemos que n es un número entero
entonces por ejemplo si nos tomamos en e
igual a menos uno tendremos menos dos
más uno son
- 1 y 12 a 2 si por ejemplo nos tomamos
menos 2 tendremos 2 x menos 2 o menos 4
+ 1 - 3
12 a vos que también queda bien si
tomamos n igual a menos 3 tendremos 2 x
menos 3 son menos seis más uno menos
cinco y doce a vos y nuevamente ya no
nos podemos tomar uno más grande porque
nos salimos de nuestro intervalo muy
bien ahora fijémonos cuales coinciden
con los de esta forma los que coinciden
con esta forma por ejemplo cuando n es
cero nos queda pido o sea dos muy bien
aquí está cuando en es uno tendremos
cuatro más uno son cinco pi doceavos que
tenemos éste tiene fuera dos ya
tendríamos 9 pi doceavos que se pasa de
depp y medio es verdad entonces ya no
nos podemos seguir adelante pero también
podemos tomar números negativos por
ejemplo si aquí fuera menos 1 tendríamos
4 x menos 1 son menos cuatro más uno son
menos 3 y 12 a 2
y si nos tomamos menos 2 tendríamos
menos 2 por 4 es menos 81 son menos 7
pido seamos y se pasa entonces realmente
aquí están nuestras soluciones y si ya
contamos son tres soluciones ok y
entonces nuestra respuesta parcial
podrían ser tres soluciones y ahora hay
que fijarnos que no sean de la forma n
pie entre 5 y no lo son verdad porque
son de la forma en el pie entre 12 así
que todo va bien y la respuesta son 33
simplemente son tres valores de teta que
cumplen todas estas restricciones